everybody wants a great body but nobody
wants to work out hey you know good
understand is that progress equals
happiness when narrowing down your goal
I encourage you to think small do what
my friend Nate green suggests and shrink
the change that is the key to making so
many of your dreams come true want to be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey Tippin Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believed life and learn how to
keep your 20/20 resolutions okay let's
kick it off with rule number one get
momentum with Tony Robbins there's
something unique about New Year's that
tends to inspire us I think it's part of
this idea that you know if you have a
fresh calendar maybe of a fresh start
you know a new perspective new actions
new results maybe a chance for a new
victory in your life so it feels like
the new year we can almost reinvent
ourselves it's kind of like new year new
you new year new life so but in truth
the calendars arbitrary and that's why
so many people participate in New Year's
resolutions that I get horrible results
it's because there's something inside of
us that wants to make things better we
want to be better as people I want to
become more do more share more create
more give more but you know it's not
quite what really works for us because
we want all these things we think are
gonna make us happy we're gonna grow and
contribute but then what happens is
everybody wants a great body but nobody
wants to work out hey you know we can
understand is that progress equals
happiness if you know what you want you
can make consistent progress you're
gonna get there you're gonna get to
where you really want to be where that
sense of passion aliveness the results
you want really do occur have a religion
that resolution yes but make it a real
resolution it's a result you're
committed to that excites you step 1
remember a compelling vision what do you
truly want what excites you what needs
it needs to be specific and measurable
and most importantly it's got to get
your energy going - you need strong
enough reason to follow through in the
tough situation show up a purpose that
drives you 3 you need that massive
action plan that map a core action list
that helps you close the gap but where
you are where you want to be and you
need to know the 20% is gonna make most
of progress and finally step 4 what do
you want to become what do you want to
do what do you want experience what do
you want to contribute what do you want
to give what do you want to master so
what do you want this year to be about
what are you really desire most what do
you want to contribute this year what
gonna be your map and one of the rituals
is gonna make it real please for your
benefit don't just watch this video do
something right the end here
to get you going and get you some
initial momentum you take action today
you can get anything change but you got
to do it while you're in state rule
number two get clear with Matt Diavel on
the first suggestion that I'll make is
to get very specific and clear about
your resolution and also commit to the
change so instead of the resolution I
want to read more this year you might
say I will read one book a month this
year you're now turning an idle wish
into an actionable plan it's much easier
to write off I once and I'd like to when
narrowing down your goal I encourage you
to think small do what my friend Nate
green suggests and shrink the change on
a scale of one to ten how confident are
you that you can actually go to the gym
three times a week I think about your
schedule think about what you have going
on look at the next week and if the
client answers anything less than us
like a 7 or less like one not confident
10 very confident that's a seven or less
we shrink it how about two days a week
mmm
seven how about one day a week well I
could do that it's like easy anyone can
go to the gym one day a week and that's
the habit that we start with and it
seems like such a small change but for
someone who's never really worked out
before if they consistently go to the
gym one day a week that's 52 workouts in
a year when they may have done zero
beforehand remember this isn't a sprint
you're looking to build habits that will
potentially last hopefully last a
lifetime and if you're able to find the
right habits to stick even if it's
waking up an extra thirty minutes
earlier it can have a massive impact on
your future if you're having trouble
figuring out your resolution or don't
know which direction to head here's a
helpful exercise get a piece of paper
and pen and write what your dream day
would look like get crazy detailed what
time you wake up what do you eat for
breakfast when do you exercise who are
you with from there you'll be able to
reverse engineer into that future day by
building one habit at a time I can't
stress you how important it is to really
write things down whether it's on a
computer or you pull out an actual
and a piece of paper and write down the
direction that you want to take your
life or the habit that you're looking to
build and even id8 and come up with an
idea of the ways in which you're gonna
make this habit stick also if you want
to have confidence in self-love check
out by 254 series they're free the link
to join on the description below so
while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions it's
about what you're saying to yourself but
it also comes at work
so whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
your mind is always eavesdropping on
your self-talk right and you have to be
careful what you say to yourself because
it's this unconscious command rule
number three change your beliefs with
Jim quick someone's watching this they
have a thing that something they want to
change and it's not it's not sticking
then maybe it's not it's the environment
maybe you could check about your habits
but maybe it's your beliefs and your
values some people will not get
themselves to read every day because
they don't value reading every single
day right some people won't work they
say the behavior they won't change is
you know we did a podcast of how to
remember names I could teach them
step-by-step on how to remember the name
of most people that they meet yet they
won't do it because they don't value it
or because that's not important to them
or they don't believe that they can
write just like we talked about earlier
saying your brain is like a
supercomputer and you know your
self-talk as a programmer run so if you
tell yourself not go to memory names you
will not remember the name the next
person you meet because you program your
supercomputer not to they don't have a
belief that enables that so when I say
all behaviors belief driven if you want
to do this behavior whatever it is
journal whatever it is then you need a
belief that allows that to happen
because you mean that's the program that
allows it so how do you get that belief
because you're gonna feel like you're
faking it all right that's where most
people stop right they think okay I get
it I hear what Jim is saying that if I
am able to shift my belief that I can
get a different behavior but I don't
believe it so now I'm just sort of
faking it
how do you help people overcome it right
and so you mean so some people approach
it by they know that it's quote where
they fake it so they make it right and
so my thing with belief is like when I
do trainings and groups or are online my
favorite way of changing the belief is
getting them to do something they never
thought they could
because it opens up another possibility
right so so for example in 1954 Roger
Bannister he broke the four-minute mile
right and so which is amazing right
throughout human history nobody can run
a mile in less than four minutes now if
you if you look into it how he was able
to do it is he would visualize himself
crossing the finish line looking at the
clock and it says 359 because he knew
that success is an inside-out process
that first it had to happen in here
in order prepped and out there right um
dr. Wayne Dyer has the famous phrase
where it's not oh I'll believe it when I
see it it's like I'll see it when I
believe it because it's the opposite
right and so yeah I've always liked
modeling the outliers where most people
kind of just like kind of dismissed them
I was like well what's what's going on
there that loves this person to get this
kind of results right and so with Roger
Bannister he saw it in here be able to
produce it outside just like any
innovator or inventor or writer any
creator right but what was interesting
is after that would happen nobody could
do it from the beginning of humanity all
of a sudden one person does it what
happens after that everybody yeah
everyone starts doing it and so that's
the thing now what happened was there
big change that year and you know
training methodology and nutrition or no
it was a change of belief right because
the belief back then was if you ran a
mile less than four minutes not only
would you die it was your heart would
explode in your chest and like think
about like that would and I'm a runner
right that would keep me not just
running that won't keep me from running
form without keep me from running period
right right and so my thing is like that
was a change of a reference I was just
shook up a belief so my goal with people
and when it comes to learning is get
themselves to do something they never
thought they could do and then it opens
up another possibility it literally
opens up their their nervous system for
something what else could be possible
when I grew up I you know we didn't have
any we we had no money right I had no
education because I was a very learning
challenge I didn't know any anybody
right so I feel like it's not when
people are that's where they'll go
though when they when they hit them in a
gap stop gap between where they are
where they want to be they'll say oh I
don't have the money or and all the
education or on the intelligence out of
the network or anything else like that
and you know what would you know
for all incredible success you've had
and the value of you created for the
world is that it's not about resources
right because we know a lot of people
who who didn't have any resources that
were able to impact the world
it's about our internal resources and
what I'm saying is optimizing our
environment optimizing our behaviors or
capabilities our beliefs and our values
and our identity right that at the
highest level our identity because you
can't just change your belief or your
values or your behavior even if you
don't believe you're that kind of person
and that's why I kind of always go to
the superhero mythos because I I want
people that get to claim that identity I
call it the superhero you that version
of ourselves and we're not waiting for
Superman or Batman or Wonder Woman it's
like you are Wonder Woman you are Batman
you are Superman it's just we we have to
commit ourselves to be able to
unleashing I'm rule number four the last
one before a very special bonus tip is
find someone to hold you accountable
with David Goggins if you believe in
Santa Claus and you celebrate Christmas
you looking forward to Santa Claus
coming down a chimney giving you some
presents it's a real good time of year
so in that good time of year we start to
feel real good about ourselves so I
start to feel great so we start making
promises to ourselves about hey I'm
going to lose some weight I'm gonna do
better in school I'm gonna be better
here to be better there but guess what
happens the real Merry Christmas happens
when all of that noise is gone it's
quiet and it's you against you and now
all those endorphins are gone and I
promise me by getting up early and
getting after to go lose weight study
harder
guess what it's lot harder now that
repetition becomes a lot harder now so
la bus can't do things on their own so
find somebody in your life so when you
throw that towel in they fill them back
at you and say enough done yet stay true
to yourself stay hard now a special
bonus clip from Chase Jarvis on how to
declare your intention that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point lighting
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one who can hold you
accountable to follow-through number two
what's the belief that you need to
change to get moment
and number three what gold you need to
make even more clear and if you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well I think the way to
morena I guess and get a way for me to
get into the show is to share an email
that I just received I think it's an
inspirational email I thought it was
worth sharing I tweaked a couple of
details to protect the person who sent
it but in general it goes like this hey
chase it worked
everything you said worked I declared
myself a photographer I got business
cards set up a business I pumped out
photographs and handed them out and
shared them on social I decided that
this is who I am I'm a photographer I'm
a creator and it's like the whole world
started conspiring in my favor the best
part is that my dad who always told me
that photography was a waste of time
now respects me respects my art my life
has changed because you gave me the time
of day thanks for everything
I would like you to think about that
that email in context of one thing and
that is declaring your intention that is
the key to making so many of your dreams
come true in fact it's sort of it is
like the stating of the dream that's all
that's what an intention is the the
intention that this gentleman set for
himself
it wasn't literally about getting cards
and starting a business license it's
really about saying who you are what do
you want to be where are you right now
but more importantly where do you want
to go and in a sense by declaring this
commitment in you know in this case to
your own creativity or toward whatever
thing that you endeavor or aspire toward
you can make big things happen
if you want to know the one simple
morning routine that will change your
life check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you do any new habit and practice
it for 66 days and you will arrive in
the place of automaticity